perhaps an interesting one to look at
because it's quite a clever design when
it was produced is the Apple 2 so we
have a corrupted Apple 2 so let me just
turn it off and on again the technology
changes with the method stay the same so
the Apple 2 we've got a Apple boot
whopper here five and a quarter inch
this sir machine actually came from the
Cambridge Centre for computing histories
so notice the noise it made or I'll
switch it on that was the heads on the
drive being sent straight back to the
first track on this so it could start
loading in the operating system for the
Apple 2 had an interesting arrangement
for storing the data because steve
wozniak when he created it managed a
completely reduce the amount of
electronics needed to drive the floppy
drive compared to all the other machines
at the time the way that a floppy disc
and certain tape formats will store the
data is that they will encode the binary
data so the 0 and the 1 that the
computer needs to store so it encodes a
1 by changing the flux produced so if
it's one-way it'll change it to the
other then it's that way it'll change it
back to when he wants to store a 1 it
encodes a 0 by saying that I'm going to
leave the magnetic flux polarity is
recording the same thing as what the
previous bit of information was so
that's how it encodes the information
the problem with that is you can't just
write the ones and zeros of the byte
that you want to record to the disk
because if you have a large string of
zeros because the timings aren't
accurate and vary between two different
floppy drives you wouldn't be able to
sync the computer to the actual data
coming off the disk and there whether
there was to 0 bits here
or was it 3 0 bits that was on a machine
that's riding too fast or am i reading 3
0 bits on machine that's reading too
slowly etc so you have to set down
certain rules for how the information is
stored so what Steve wasn't yet decided
to do is use a thing called group code
recording to encode the data so rather
than storing the 8 bits of data then he
wanted to store directly onto the disk
because of these things you couldn't do
that what he actually did was to say I'm
going to encode this data in a specific
way so he what he did is he took 5 bits
of the data he wanted to
and he had two rules that he use to
store the information on the disk
firstly he said I've got to write into 8
bits at a time
and each of those 8 bits is going to
start with a 1 so the most significant
bit of the byte that he's going to write
will start with a 1 so that was his
first rule that all the bytes will start
with a specific one
the second rule he said was they could
only be a maximum of one zero bits
between any two 1 bits that were written
out this meant that the electronic could
easily keep in sync with the data as it
came off the disk and work out what bits
are being recorded what this means is is
a code like 1 0 1 1 1 0 1 1 is
absolutely fine to use because it meets
both rules we've got a 1 as the most
significant bit and we have no more than
at least 1 0 bit between any 2 ones on
the other hand to code like 0 1 1 1 1 1
1 that wouldn't be allowed and 1 is
allowed because we're starting with a 0
and because we know that all the bytes
start with a 1 we can easily lock onto
the first most significant bit of the
byte because we know it must be a 1 also
a code like this wouldn't be allowed
because we've got 2 0 bits in succession
there are only 34 different 8-bit values
that meet both these two rules I they
start with 1 and they have no more than
1 0 between any two 1 bits 34 different
possible values gives us enough
information to encode 5 binary bits of
data so five bits of data that which is
2 to the power of 5 is 32 which is less
than the 30 for different value so what
Steve wasn't that good in software
rather than in hardware like everyone
else was doing at the time was to take
five bits of data from the that he
wanted to store and using a lookup table
in memory convert it into whichever of
the codes was used to store that data if
we look at the floppy drive we have here
is it cheaper was that cheaper to make
us it was cheaper to make because a lot
of the controllers are here or to do
things like control the stepper motor
that drive the head backwards or forward
and spin the disc he was able to replace
that with software control things on the
i/o card for the Apple 2 he had to be
very clever and build a very specialized
processor based around a ROM chip to
actually read the data back in but to
write the data he could do it all
through software very clever design
which people respected does the flop you
have some kind of table of contest I
don't know where to start with anything
well this is a very good question is
actually two things you need to be a
world is first of all you need to know
where the file actually is that you want
to access on the disk which sector it is
on on which track so if we want to
access the file let's call it CP we need
to know that it's stored at track 2
sector 2 and so on and so we'd have a
catalog on the disk that would say that
CP begins at track 2 sector 2 and so all
the disk file formats you've got
basically our ways of mapping from file
names to different tracks and sectors on
the disk how do you know where sector 1
starts on the disk and that you're not
reading sector 2 or how sector 3 starts
on the disk five and a quarter inch disk
so if I move the light here so as I spin
it you'll see there's a little hole and
there's a sensor inside the drive which
will actually look for that hole it's
just a light shining through it to a set
on the other and that will tell it where
it becomes to the beginning of the track
so that allowed it to orient itself
basically exactly there's a way of
finding out where I was
so the first floppy disk actually had
another index hole and so each of the
sectors were hard marked on the disk
with holes so that you could actually
detect where you were but one of the
other things that Steve Wozniak's
decided to do was to use some of the
unused codes that he had he had 34 codes
but only 32 of them to represent the
data you're storing to mean the
beginning of a sector so he used e 5 and
a a in hex as values to represent the
bidding at the beginning of a sector so
that whenever you saw the sequence D 5 a
a nine six you knew you'd become to the
start of a sector because that sequence
was guaranteed and never appear in the
actual data because neither D 5 or a a
were used to represent data so you could
mark the beginning of the sector and
actually you could do that with Claire
things he didn't actually necessarily
need to use the index hole at all this
is called his soft sector disk in all
hard disks and modern floppies use that
doing a true bit of trivia on those in
South Africa they're nicknamed stiffies
that may not make the final cut